in the FED investors trust even as its
campaign to raise interest rates causes
turmoil in the stock Bond currency and
commodity markets and increases the odds
of a global recession Bloomberg pulled a
group of professional and Retail
investors asking them which Central Bank
will succeed in cooling inflation and
getting the cost of living under control
the U.S one-handedly that may be because
the rest of the world faces additional
pressures for the UK and Europe it's an
energy shortage sparked by war in
Ukraine while China is still pursuing
its coveted zero policy in other words
the U.S is the cleanest dirty shirt in
the global laundry basket so it follows
that survey respondents also
overwhelmingly picked the U.S economy as
a relative winner seen emerging from the
global turmoil first along with U.S
stocks and bonds now looking ahead one
unspoken downside risk in a recovery is
a potential widening in inequality the
stock market would rally boosting the
portfolios of the wealthy while
stagnating pay and high rents would
squeeze lower income households
foreign